it keeps going
on in my head
and i can't stop it
[Applause]
there you have it i'm a journalist i
covered your fight i'm interested in
your story everybody knows my story i'm
the survivor of auschwitz
you fight until one man can no longer
get up
[Applause]
my girl from back home
she doesn't know that i'm alive
but if my name is in the papers
i want to fight marciano i will plaster
your story all over the east coast
it says that you made a deal to survive
by fighting
europe waiter
you think leia's gone
i hope she's alive
and we'll keep looking for her i have to
be famous across america enough with the
glamour shot sweeta hey with come on get
in here
marciano's bigger he hits harder you
were taught wrong from the beginning
i'll give you two days training why
would you help me win
win
boychick i'm just giving you a chance to
lose with a little dignity
i fought for her
and that was the only reason for
fighting
six million of our people are dead why
did you survive if not to live
i've heard every imaginable awful thing
you can talk to me why is this god asked
so much of us
[Music]
didn't want fear in your heart
who deserves to have that kind of
darkness inside of their children is
life
for yours
these are the choices we made every day
choices made when you'll remember that
you've answered the family
way
you